je peux pas accepter cette impression au
contraire on a démontré ces derniers
mois qu'on se laisse pas intimider par
la russie vous savez que des sanctions
sont prises et ont été régulièrement
renouvelés à l'encontre de la de la
russie nous considérons qu'il est
impératif de mettre en oeuvre les
accords de minsk qui sont extrêmement
importants pour faire respecter les
souverainetés les intercités
territoriales aux frontières de l'union
européenne
nous considérons aussi nous devons être
engagées notamment avec les pays du
partenariat oriental et c'est ce que
nous faisons lorsque par exemple je suis
en effet personnellement pour faciliter
une médiation en georgie et ramener la
stabilité politique dans le pays
c'est un message de soutien pour essayer
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
institutions démocratiques robuste et
plus robuste dans le pipe c'est aussi un
message que nous adressons à la à la
russie lorsqu'une sommes engagés pour
renforcer les liens entre l'union
européenne et le temps il n'y aura dans
quelques semaines à bruxelles un sommet
de l'otan et en marge d'une réunion
institutionnelle être le président joe
biden
ce sont des coopérations et des messages
nous adressons pour porter ensemble des
valeurs et de son désintérêt
[Musique]